More than a dozen Democrats are sparring for the party's nomination.
The winner will take on President Trump in the general election on November 3rd, 2020.
Here are the Democratic candidates running to become the next president of the United States.
Joe Biden was vice president for eight years under Barack Obama...
...and is running on a message of bipartisanship and national unity.
A centrist with national name recognition,...
...Biden pulls well among the white working class and African-American voters,...
...both key constituencies of the Democratic base.
Billionaire and former New York City mayor Michael Bloomberg...
...initially announced he would not run for president.
But concerned by the liberal lean of the Democrats in the Primary,...
...he announced his self-funded run in November.
Pete Buttigieg is the youngest presidential candidate...
...and one of only two US veterans in the race.
Dogged by questions about his ability to appeal to younger voters and voters of color,...
...the former Rhodes scholar has nonetheless risen to the top of early polls in Iowa and New Hampshire.
The former Mayor of Burlington, Vermont, Bernie Sanders was the runner-up in 2016.
The longtime Vermont senator is again running on the same unapologetically liberal platform...
...including Medicare for all and free college.
But this time, he's not alone.
Many of the other candidates on the debate stage have since embraced his positions.
As a law professor, Elizabeth Warren helped create the Consumer Financial Protection Bureau...
...before she was elected to represent Massachusetts in the Senate in 2012.
Born in Oklahoma to a working-class family,...
...her campaign is built in part on her personal experience with tough pocketbook issues...
...like affording childcare and in part on her dozens of detailed policy proposals.